everybody so the news is out that
Gourmet magazine is shutting down and
first and foremost i feel bad for
anybody that works there and good luck
I'm sure it's a bit agree magazine I'm
sure you have the talent to go out and
succeed but what I want to talk to you
about is something very interesting this
is marked up a lot of purple things
might get in here
zooming up a little bit there's a lot of
ads in here mr. Martin kela action
taco stuffed rabble there is where's
this going I mean I'm very curious we're
you know the survey side where it is
where does Macy's out well let me tell
you where it's going where everybody's
been telling you that it's gonna go I
don't understand it's insane to me how
many people like oh is this a sign of
the times like wow this is a real this
has been going on everybody knows it's
coming
of course patron they were stupid to buy
this act for a couple thousand dollars
in the first place because if you went
here and you built community and you got
in the trenches as a brand it would be a
much better buy so where's this going to
all the people that are producing video
blogs and written blogs about gourmet
food that's what's happening folks in
here the infrastructure costs are much
cheaper see content is going nowhere
content is always king these journalists
going nowhere
they're gonna go to a direct platform
where if they're good they're gonna keep
more of the action see the supply and
demand of content is broken when there
was only Gourmet magazine years ago or
two other competitors and you liked
reading about it well then you had a buy
it but now you go here have you heard of
Google search gourmet there's a ton of
[ __ ] so the bottom line is this
what are these ads going it was stupid
for Mercedes to buy this in the first
place and once they realize where to
send it all the individual entrepreneurs
were the three-person teams about people
that are passionate about food you want
to reach the food demo you got
passionate about food go build a food
site talk about it your cost is much
lower and Mercedes is gonna come calling
for you because guess what
good for a new home